the rescue team members are being taken
to shanghai hospital for medical checks
a thai newspaper reported the names and
photos of the four boys who were
admitted yesterday after their rescue
Thailand's interior minister says they
are strong and safe and a Warner is at
the hospital Anna good morning good
morning earlier today police came
through here and pushed the media back
setting up these metal barricades
presumably to keep that entrance to the
hospital clear now the four boys who are
here already receiving treatment there
between 14 and 16 years old staff here
at the hospital reserved the entire
eighth floor for them as they receive
that specialized medical attention each
of them is undergoing detailed medical
checks for about three to five days here
doctors will be looking out for some
immediate problems like dehydration and
malnutrition those 14s they arrived at
the hospital yesterday after a 37 mile
journey by helicopters and ambulances
that were on standby at the cave site
and the hospital now reportedly has a
book inside reserved for visitors to
come by right encouraging and special
messages to the teens as they recover
Gayle
and a Warner in Thailand thank you